are you glad to be back Mr Bowden yes
thank you day one of a new government
and no time to lose key sunac allies get
into work before Dawn
his entire cabinet convening through the
morning Jennifer
and already agreeing changes that big
financial statement due Monday now
delayed his arrival reassuring the
markets come in the cabinet and create
an a bit more confidence among
colleagues our number one priority is
economic stability
and restoring confidence that the United
Kingdom is a country that pays its way
the Prime Minister and I have decided
that it is prudent to make that
statement on the 17th of November when
it will be upgraded to a full Autumn
statement
an upgrade he approved this will be a
government-defining Autumn statement
[Applause]
this a moment to off to Parliament for
his first pmqs
entering the chamber to Cheers but
stopped in his tracks his path ahead not
straightforward in the seat he longed
for finally a smile but soon the attacks
came the labor leader targeting the
former tax status of the new PM's wife
she says he'll protect the most
vulnerable Let's test that the
government currently allows very rich
people to live here but register abroad
for tax purposes I don't need to explain
to the Prime Minister how non-dom status
Works he already knows all about that
why doesn't he put his mouth where his
money where his mouth is I'd get rid of
it the digs kept on coming but Mr sunak
was Keen to dismiss and move on well Mr
Speaker I have been honors we will have
to take difficult decisions to restore
economic stability and confidence and my
honorable friend the chancellor will set
that out at a Norton statement in just a
few weeks today a sense of what the next
few weeks and months might look like
breaking with the final strands of the
trust Administration restoring 2019
Manifesto commitments on fracking
reinstating that ban promised in the
last election yesterday he promised to
fix her mistakes as well as to to uphold
the party's 2019 Manifesto so if he is a
man of his word will he start by
reversing the green light she gave to
fracking I've already said I stand by
the manifesto on that and on benefits a
strong hint too will he today reassure
people and guarantee that benefits will
rise in line with inflation in his
upcoming budget I always acted in a way
to protect the most vulnerable that's
because it is the right thing to do and
those are the values of our
compassionate party and I can absolutely
reassure him and give him that
commitment that we will continue to act
like that in the weeks ahead disappear
looking ahead but older problems look
set to haunt him continue questions
about the controversial reappointment of
a Home Secretary last week forced to
resign for sharing official documents
via her personal email
was his Home Secretary right to resign
last week for a breach of security the
Home Secretary made an error of judgment
but she recognized that she raised the
matter and she accepted her mistake we
can all see what's happened here he's so
weak he's done a grubby deal creating
National Security because he was scared
to lose another leadership election but
what he also came under Fire for prime
minister's questions is his refusal to
hold a general election it's obvious why
not the conservatives fear they'd be
absolutely trounced at The Ballot Box
according to polls at the moment but Mr
sunac knows too that changing the party
leader and prime minister not once but
twice without an election has left the
legitimacy of his government hanging by
a thread so it's Back to Basics and back
to the 2019 Manifesto
for now things around here are Karma
some respite from stormy times but the
political and economic headwinds are
still very much against the new PM bath
Rigby Sky News Westminster